your character celebrates Trump's  victory in a very unusual way my getting  this right I mean he covers his face in  Cheetos and then humps the television  that's right I think we have a still of  your character doing that that's covered  in first of all that's an odd way I mean  people had very different reactions to  that election yeah I've never heard of  anyone having that reaction right I'd  get excited sometimes yeah I see that TV  right there yeah I think the battery  came out of your microphone while you  were busy screwing the television set  yeah this is this thing work it doesn't  purchases yeah yeah all right like  Candy's the tech guy everybody  alright I'll come back later because  Andy's here in case anything goes wrong  with the battery right now that's that's  going to be in the Union lawsuit that's  the  [Laughter]  you